.
>> Dan: YOU'RE DOING REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK DOWN THERE,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SADLY REFUSING TO ENFORCE THE
LAW THE BORDER BUT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY DOING THE SAME THING IN
OUR NATION AS WELL.
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
HANDCUFFED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
FOR EXAMPLE, I SUPPORTED FEWER
THAN 3,000 PEOPLE LAST MONTH,
THE LOWEST LEVEL ON RECORD
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WHICH
CALLS ICE AND AGENCY ON
PROBATION HERE TO FIGHT AND ALSO
REPORTEDLY PLANS TO CANCEL AN
EFFORT UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP
THAT WOULD'VE ASKED GREEN CARD
APPLICANTS OF OTHER EVER BEEN
PART OF A CRIMINAL GANG.
U.S. CITIZENSHIP AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES SAID TODAY IN A
STATEMENT THEY MADE NO FINAL
DECISIONS ABOUT THAT AND ANY
PROPOSED CHANGES GO TO THE
APPROPRIATE PROCEDURES AND AS WE
MENTIONED EARLIER, THE BUDGET
JUST RELEASED TODAY REQUESTS
ONLY 0.1% FUNDING INCREASE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY WHICH INCLUDES ICE.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ONLY GETS
A 5.6% INCREASE WHILE EVERY
OTHER DEPARTMENT GETS DOUBLE
DIGIT INCREASE.
IN ANNOUNCING THE BUDGET TODAY,
CALLED IT A STATEMENT OF VALUE,
SHOULD'VE CALLED IT A STATEMENT
OF BANKRUPTCY.
APPARENTLY, BORDER SECURITY AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AREN'T THINGS HE
VALUES AT ALL.
HERE WITH REACTION, ARIZONA
CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGGS AND
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP STEPHEN MILLER.
I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST, JUST
LISTENING TO THE REPORT IN ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT DISTURBED ME
ABOUT THIS, REMEMBER WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP RECOVERED FROM
CORONAVIRUS AND SECRET SERVICE
AGENTS VOLUNTEERED TO TAKE HIM
IN THE CAR SO HE COULD SHOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HE IS OKAY AND
THE MEDIA HAD AN UPROAR ALL IN
PROTECTIVE OUTFITS AND
PROTECTIVE GARB AND SAID OH, MY
GOSH, HE'S PUTTING THEM IN
DANGER OF CORONAVIRUS.
YOU KNOW IT'S FASCINATING?
YOU HAVE ALL THESE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS, DOCUMENTED CASES, PEOPLE
COULD BE KILLED BY THIS AND THE
MEDIA ALL OF A SUDDEN -- HAVE
YOU HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT THAT?
NOT A PEEP.
>> IS A GREAT POINT AND WHEN
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WHO SHOW UP AT THE BORDER DO SO,
THEY ARE NOT WEARING MASKS OR
FACE SHIELDS, HAVE BEEN IN SOME
OF THE MOST UNSANITARY AND
UNHYGIENIC ENVIRONMENTS
IMAGINABLE, IT SAID
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL DISASTER IN
THESE BORDER AGENTS RELY ON
PUTTING THEIR BODIES ON THE LINE
TO KEEP THIS COUNTRY SAFE DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
MY ORGANIZATION ALONG WITH THE
STATE OF TEXAS IS SUING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR
VIOLATING THEIR OWN RULES ON OUR
SOUTHWEST BORDER PUTTING OUR
COMMUNITIES AT RISK FOR THE
BENEFIT OF ILLEGAL ALIENS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE ICE ISSUE, I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THIS, THESE ARE CRIMINALS BEING
SET FREE, 92% UNDER DONALD TRUMP
HAD CRIMINAL CHARGES OR
CONVICTIONS WHERE THEY ARE
SLASHING DEPORTATIONS, GANG
MEMBERS, FELONS, PEOPLE GUILTY
OF SEX CRIMES GOING FREE AND
THEN ON TOP OF THAT, YOU HAVE
ACTIVELY PLANNING TO GET RID OF
SCREENING FOR GREEN CARDS SAYING
WE WERE WORKING ON AND NOW I
HAVE SEEN THE DRAFT DOCUMENTS
SHOWING THEM TRYING TO GET RID
OF THAT SCREENING QUESTION,
THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Dan: WHEN STEPHEN WAS IN
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE AND I KNOW
YOU FOLLOWED THIS AS WELL BEING
INACTIVE CONGRESSMAN ON THE
ISSUE, NOT FIXED, THE PROBLEM
WAS NEVER SOLVED BUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAD DONE THAT
WORK IN GETTING A HOLD OF THAT
SOUTHERN BORDER.
REALLY, YOU HAVE TO BE A
DEMOCRAT TO CREATE A PROBLEM FOR
A SOLUTION.
THIS PROBLEM WAS BEING FIXED,
REMAIN IN MEXICO, THE ASYLUM
RULES AND THEY SCREWED THIS UP.
THIS IS ABSURD.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
INHERITED A SOLUTION AND IT IS
EVERYTHING YOU SAY, EVERYTHING
FROM STOPPING DEFENSE FROM
PROVIDING DOLLARS TO ILLEGAL
ALIENS WHO COME ACROSS THE
STOPPING THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY, THE AGREEMENT AND NOW
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT EMASCULATING
ICE EVEN FURTHER BUT THESE ARE
CRIMINALS THAT ICE GOES AFTER,
THE ONES WHO NEED TO BE REMOVED
FROM THE COUNTRY NOT MORE THAN
ANYBODY ELSE TO KEEP THIS
COUNTRY SAFE IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WON'T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS, THE SECRETARY
JUST SAID THIS WEEK THE BORDER
IS CLOSED.
WHEN I WAS DOWN THERE JUST A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO, IT WAS A
STEADY STREAM OF PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS AND SURRENDERING AND THAT
WAS IN THE YUMA SECTOR AND THIS
IS EVERYWHERE ALONG THE BORDER
THEY ARE NOT DOING ENOUGH, NOT
DOING ANYTHING BECAUSE I TRULY
BELIEVE YOU CAN'T BEAT THIS
INCOMPETENT.
THEY HAVE TO DESIRE THIS, THEY
CAMPAIGNED FOR OPEN BORDERS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE.
>> Dan: YOU SAID SOMETHING THE
OTHER NIGHT AND I DON'T REMEMBER
THE SHOW BUT YOU SAID SOMETHING
THAT REALLY GOT UNDER MY SKIN,
YOU SAID IT'S AMAZING THESE
HOTELS WE ARE SPENDING TENS OF
MILLIONS THE HOUSE PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AND YOU
BROUGHT UP THE POINT WE HAVE
HOMELESS VETERANS OUT THERE WHO
FOUGHT FOR THIS COUNTRY,
AMERICAN CITIZENS WITH
PSYCHOLOGICAL PROBLEMS ON THE
STREET AND SPENDING TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO SHIELD
PEOPLE WHO COULD HAVE COME HERE
ILLEGALLY AND SAID I DON'T THINK
SO, WE WILL DISREGARD THE LAW
AND DO WHAT WE WANT.
>> WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP RAN FOR
OFFICE, HE USED TO SAY WE TREAT
ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THIS COUNTRY
BETTER THAN VETERANS.
WHEN HE GOT ELECTED, HE SWITCH
THAT AND SECURED OUR BORDER.
WE ARE NOW LITERALLY LIVING IN A
TIME, NOT HYPERBOLE, IT IS FACT
THAT WE HAVE HOMELESS VETERANS
AND WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
USING TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO HOUSE
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
NEXT TIME YOU SEE A VETERAN ON
THE STREET WHO NEEDS HELP, WHO
NEEDS A PATH FORWARD FOR A PASS
UPWARD, JUST REMEMBER YOUR TAX
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO HELP
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR HOURS IN VIOLATION
OF OUR LAWS TO TAKE AMERICAN
JOBS AND AMERICAN BENEFITS.
IT IS A THUNDEROUS VIOLATION OF
THE SOCI